la vitesse juste de les avoir
juste les voir passer c'est tripad non
on est situé dans une tribune où on voit
les voitures à la dernière minute
arriver donc on a une compétition dans
les estrades d'identifier en premier
c'est quel pilote avec faut reconnaître
le casque pour connaître l'aileron pour
connaître savoir si elle est jaune ou
noir c'est comme un défi de famille
des amateurs de la Formule 1 ça se
déroule ce week-end à Montréal à chaque
formule 1 à chaque Grand Prix au fond il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de visiteurs tous
les restaurants sont plein les hôtels
sont pleins et la nourriture débordent
parce qu'il faut tout nourrir pour
nourrir toutes ces équipes là et puis il
y a beaucoup de nourriture qui se
gaspille mais il y a une initiative
se tient pour la deuxième année c'est
comment éviter le gaspillage alimentaire
mais comment on s'y prend mais c'est une
initiative de la table des chefs je
parle à son fondateur que vous voyez à
l'écran Jean-François Archambault
bonsoir Jean-François Chambaud bonsoir
alors parlez-nous de cette initiative
c'est vrai que il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de nourriture
en fait on
réalise pas comment c'est un site qui
est complexe quand même souvent je
disais les chefs arrivent en camping ils
installent en traiteur des buffets des
installations de nourriture tant dans
les paddocks dans les concessions et
tout ça donc c'est c'est on doit y avoir
après 80 000 personnes sur le site donc
ça fait énormément de nourriture et ça
fait c'est la deuxième année où on est
sur le site avec l'équipe des bénévoles
qu'on mobilise et qui vont assurer que
toutes les équipes de cuisine qui nous
connaissent maintenant
puissent utiliser les contenants garder
cette nourriture là et sur le site il y
a un camion réfrigéré dans lequel on
peut déposer les contenants et on a fait
le relais avec des organismes
communautaires qui viendront tout au
long du week-end chercher c'est surplus
alimentaires
à plusieurs moments dans la journée tout
le week-end parce que le lunch il y a
les collation tout ça vous récupérez au
fur et à mesure un roulement qui se fait
il y a des membres de mon équipe qui
sont là et s'ajoutent des bénévoles qui
l'ont fait l'an dernier et qui voulaient
le refaire cette année parce que pour
eux c'est quelque chose de magique de
voir c'est rare qu'on est sur un site
souvent on a mis en place le programme
de récupération dans les établissements
ou chutes dans les services alimentaires
du chemin on récupère énormément de
nourriture dans les hôtels dans d'autres
types d'événements où on n'est pas sur
place et là au grand prix là c'est
nécessaire d'être sur place avec une
équipe ça demande énormément de
logistique quand même la chaîne de froid
chaîne de show doit être maintenue on
doit quand même faire circuler des
aliments très rapidement les remettre au
froid et s'assurer que on puisse
récupérer un maximum de nourriture
l'année dernière c'était 14 tonnes de
nourriture qu'on a récupéré à peu près
la moitié c'est de la nourriture
préparée donc de la nourriture de buffet
de de
banquiers ça peut être des viandes
tranchées ça peut des légumes grillés
des salades de tomates avec mozzarella
ça c'est ce que vous voyez normalement
dans des grands buffets dans des grands
banquets c'est ce type de d'aliments là
qui n'importe qui rêverait d'avoir les
surplus le lendemain d'une fête des
chefs
à la maison on récupère après avoir reçu
la famille donc c'est juste normal qu'on
puisse s'assurer de sauver ces
aliments-là ça va durer du métier de
cuisinier qui eux se lève tôt le matin à
chaque matin pour préparer tous ces
aliments là pour ces gens-là qui vont
apprécier ces aliments là tous les
agriculteurs qui ont fait pousser les
légumes il y a un respect des aliments
qui qui est en place dans cette
initiative là et on salue le Grand Prix
de nous faire une place et on partage
avec eux l'enjeu du gaspillage
alimentaire et on espère là on en a
parlé de l'année prochaine d'amener le
grand public dans cette aventure là
aussi comment c'est c'est intéressant je
pense il y a presque 50% du gaspillage
qui se passe à la maison
et et on doit conscientiser les gens à
faire des petites actions à changer
leurs habitudes on le fait avec des
jeunes dans plus de 230 écoles
secondaires à travers le Québec avec le
programme des brigades culinaires donc
c'est possible de le faire à la maison
aussi extraordinaire alors c'est
vraiment une course contre la montre
comme les formules en fait comme les
voitures parce qu'un autre des bas
évidemment sur l'environnement puis
est-ce que on en a pour notre argent
avec un grand prix parce que bon c'est
des investissements publics beaucoup
alors évidemment vous aider à nourrir
les plus vulnérables ou s'en va cette
nourriture puis dans quel délai
Jean-François donc tout au long du
week-end à chaque jour il y a des
organismes à la fin des journées qui
vont venir chercher c'est environ cinq
organismes communautaires avec lesquels
on travaille qui viendront rejoindre nos
équipes on va vider le camion à chaque
jour qui va être rempli à chaque jour et
à la fin lundi toute notre équipe est là
on est tout le monde est là et là on
s'assure de récupérer tout ce qui a été
laissé dans les cuisines que qui est pas
sorti et
on ajoute à ça tout ce qui vient des
concessions qui vient presque doubler la
quantité de nourriture et de breuvage
qu'on peut parler de ça non pas de votre
initiative et de penser qu'on pense aux
gens qui avec l'inflation pour les
moyens d'aller acheter l'essentiel à
l'épicerie chaque semaine je vous dirais
c'est le fait que Grand Prix se
conscientise à ça s'appelle à nos
services pour le faire je trouve que
c'est déjà un bon poche je pense que le
débat du Grand Prix pour moi ça amène
énormément de gens en ville aussi puis
ça ça amène des choses mais nous pour
nous c'est de se concentrer sur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et cette initiative
là pour nous va permettre de nourrir des
dizaines de milliers de personnes c'est
certain que ça ne vient pas réglé madame
sous ça ne vient pas régler le problème
du gaspillage alimentaire mais en ce
moment la réduction du gaspillage
alimentaire ces aliments-là qui sont
comestibles doivent s'en aller pour
nourrir des gens dans le besoin c'est ce
qu'on fait de la table des chefs on
nourrit plus de 2 millions de personnes
par année dans plus de 200
établissements où on récupère des
surplus alimentaires et je pense que si
le Grand Prix le fait ça amène
énormément de visibilité sur l'enjeu et
ça permettra à d'autres organisations
comme le Festival Juste pour rire qui
joue à nous cet été aussi et d'autres
initiatives la SAQ a mis en place une
politique où il encourage le programme
de la tabler des chefs dans tous ces
événements où ils commandaient donc tous
les promoteurs d'événements qui
reçoivent des commandes de la SA puis
sont encouragés aussi à récupérer leurs
surplus alimentaires mais bien
évidemment on doit aussi travailler sur
la réduction à la source et la réduction
du gaspillage alimentaire
et ça ça vit pas longtemps faut vraiment
qu'elle soit redistribuée très
rapidement et en toute sécurité
c'est l'enjeu du site le site est
difficile d'accès je l'expliquais les
fournisseurs les distributeurs
alimentaires n'ont pas envie de
retourner dans une deuxième fois si je
peux vous le dire je vous ferai une
bouteille des rec cles pas les récupère
pas le champagne des fonds de bouteilles
de champagne
on en reparlera la prochaine fois mais
félicitations et félicitations parce que
vous allez devenir chevalier de l'Ordre
national du Québec c'est partager avec
mon équipe ouais mais c'est pour
reconnaître la contribution des
Québécois à notre société merci beaucoup
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI